Gary what time do you wake up in the
morning yeah my my discipline ideally
would be to get up super early in the
morning to me the most productive time
of day by far is early morning like 5
o'clock 5:30 6:00 would be late as it is
right now I've been working on a hectic
schedule so it means I get to bed a
little bit later so I've been getting up
around seven sevens pretty much my time
to get up
when I'm writing the book or what I'm
doing something special then I read Jake
and I go to bed earlier and I get up
early getting in two to three hours of
productive time before the rest of the
world's awake is the most delicious
thing one can do for oneself agreed why
do you wake up in the morning why do I
wake up in the morning I wake up the
morning cuz I'm excited about life
because there's people and there's ideas
and there's explorations to be had that
day because I have my ideas about what I
want to get done but I'm not arrogant
enough to believe that those have the
necessarily the most important of the
only things that will happen that day
but I just have an innate curiosity and
I like to challenge myself I'm more self
competitive not so much competitive with
others so to me every day it's not
opportunity to see
you know the question really comes down
to one simple thing how do you make that
day matter how do you make that day
meaningful enough to be memorable I love
that that you're competitive but not in
the sense that we hear a lot where
you've got to be better than the next
guy which I know that that's true but I
like that talk about the difference
between self competition versus
competition with everyone out there or
perceived competition and then you end
up creating enemies or vice versa
the the downside the underbelly of being
competitive by nature is that your
traditional definition of competition
has you in a perennial state of non
success you just can't win at it if I'm
comparing my I do CrossFit the exercise
of choice at least in this moment for me
in the last year year and a half has
been CrossFit if I were competing with
those around me at my gym my gyms one of
the best in the country
if I were competing against those in my
gym there's always going to be people
who are far far far more advanced far
superior athletically they their level
of fitness is off the charts they're
monkeys they're not even people so if I
were comparing myself to those people I
would I would always be in a deficit I'd
always be thinking what's missing what I
haven't accomplished right but if I'm
self competitive suddenly it flips the
script so now I'm looking at everybody
who's working on those 50 other people
30 other people so many other people
that are working on at the same time and
every one of them is an opportunity to
pick up a trick and learn something and
model remodel something I learn more by
having relationships and dialogue and
just observing these other people so
that I can push myself further faster so
I I don't look I'm not in competition
with them I'm kind of in competition
with my own sense of well-being and
discipline and what how do I push myself
because I'll progress faster by not
competing than by competing
was that always the case because I
noticed a lot of younger people are very
competitive
whereas I tend to see people maybe after
40 they tend to realize like you know
what no I think that it's more about my
goals and not comparing how well someone
else is doing over meeting that always
yeah I think we cook we all come out of
the womb competitive on some level
academically athletically in terms of
our looks and our social popularity and
all sorts of you know yeah absolutely
and that's a growing phase you know
because there are the passages I forget
what they are there's the the athlete
and there's the you know you grow into
the Statesman and then you go into the
the community altar whatever the wise
person whatever those are natural steps
in our evolution is as in this life
journey and I think age has a lot of
advantages but underneath all of that
there's a sense that I'm okay underneath
all that is what I think is that is is
the key to success and well-being not
just professionally but personally which
is self belief it's okay to like
yourself it's okay to believe in
yourself it's okay to also be patient
and give yourself permission to know
that life is a process not an event it's
not about a report card because that's a
static idea it's a snapshot that has
nothing to do with your aspiration your
aspiration is so much more it's so more
more dimensional more long-term it's a
vision and if you don't aren't driven by
a vision and you're only looking at it's
like a corporation looking at quarterly
profits and not doing the right thing
long term what's best for the company
for the employees for their stakeholders
and for the and and for the consumer
they're totally opposing views of life
so if you have self-belief and if you
can if you can if you can really dig in
and find within yourself and celebrate
that which is and sometimes people can
oftentimes people can because they
forget who they are people forget how
amazing and unique and special they are
I had an emergency room doctor years ago
I was giving a talk somewhere and he
approached me afterward and basically
was very lackluster very low-energy
complete complaining of himself that he
was tremendously average and I asked him
a few questions and it was shocking in
the span of a few moments what I learned
about this guy that was extraordinary so
he was responsible not only for being an
ER doctor which is already like oh my
gosh but he was responsible for this
large Hospital there was a series of
hospitals he was in charge of the
culture of the of the hospital chain all
incoming nurses all incoming doctors all
personnel in a knee strike who came into
this system which is a system that
welcomes on a daily basis people in
trauma people in fear people in the most
crucial critical moment of their life
surrounded by family who are equally
concerned and upset and vulnerable so
he's the guy responsible for telling
teaching doctors and nurses and everyone
who's going to interface with the public
how to be better at what they do how to
be more humane at what they do how to
understand and be empathetic in ways
they might otherwise not have chosen to
be his impact on the lives of all the
doctors all the nurses not to mention
that thousands and thousands of
countless numbers of people who
trafficked through that environment on a
daily literally daily basis is
inestimable it is not susceptible of
measurement it is beyond enormity not
just because of the numbers of people
but because of the
possibility of measuring how deeply
crucial those moments are and how they
are met here's a guy who thought he was
boring here's kinda thought I'm just
typical and average and what have you so
what I asked him to do is a personal
favor not really knowing me was if he
would go home and and and call upon
three nurses and three doctors currently
under the roof of this hospital and
three nurses and doctors who had he had
trained but had matriculated and going
on elsewhere in their life it's a dozen
people didn't have to mean
mathematically precise reach out to
these kinds of people that you had
intimate interaction with and ask them
not to respond in the moment but to be
thoughtful think about it and come back
to you if they're willing and tell you
the truth and the truth is the answer to
the following questions Who am I to you
what influence have I had in your life
how have you altered your view or or
habits or behaviors as a result of our
interactions what value do I represent
if any good bad or indifferent he called
me a month later he was like a changed
man he was ambulant he was his voice
went up an octave but he was excited he
was like oh my gosh I had no idea
who I was in the world in the eyes of so
many people I respect
anybody can do that exercise we just
don't think to do it
you